The path from the eye to the background is pretty trivial and easily handled.
An empty scene is about the easiest thing to render, so this path is not a
problem. The path from a light to any object to a diffuse object is not well
handled by ray tracing. If you ray trace from the eye to the object, you don't
know to shoot a ray in this direction. Objects can be reflective, but when the
light's contribution to a visible surface is computed, only paths directly from
the light to the surface are checked. So, this answer is indeed true, it's
ignored. For this third path, imagine you're viewing the world from a point on
the surface. If you think about it, just about every surrounding visible object
is reflecting light at the surface, not just the light sources in the scene.
Determining which paths could possibly contribute more light is difficult. Any
paths from the light source are ignored with classical ray tracing as there are
a huge number of them. So, this case is ignored. The fourth case is easy to
handle. Even rasterization typically handles lights by giving them a fixed
solid color. And classical ray tracing can treat them in the same way.